Speaker 1: Welcome to The David Pakman Show,
I'm Ferren cousins from Ring of Fire, sitting
in for David today, we've got a lot to cover,
so let's hop right into it.
First and foremost, I want to start with where
I am located, the state of Florida.
As everybody knows right now, the state of
Florida is watching as covid absolutely ravages
this state.
To complicate matters, in just a couple days
next week, most school districts here in the
state of Florida resume children going back
to school.
Virtually no mask mandates in place, and that
is thanks to an executive order signed by
our trump loving Republican Governor Ron de
Santos just a couple of weeks ago to Santos
signed an executive order expressly forbidding
school districts, counties, cities from putting
any kind of mask mandate in place.
And he followed that up, by the way, with
a threat to strip federal funding, actually
state funding, excuse me, from any school.
That implements a mask mandate at the same
time that this is happening.
Florida just two days ago.
Had over 20000 new covid cases, the second
highest day on record for us, we have had
over 40000 deaths in this state alone.
The last week of July, we had more than ten
thousand children test positive for covid-19.
Our I use are filling up.
With men, women and children as well.
And Santos is sending everybody back to school
and expressly saying you cannot implement
policies to protect these children.
That is what we are dealing with here in the
state of Florida.
There's a little bit of hope, though, right
now we have several counties that have decided
to fight back Orange County, which is the
big area of Orlando, it's where the theme
parks are huge population there.
They decided, along with Broward County down
in South Florida, another huge, huge county,
that they were going to defy to Santas and
they decided to go ahead and put the mask
mandates in place for schoolchildren.
Now, this was actually before de Santa signed
his executive order, but after his threat
of do not, you know, put a mask mandate in
place.
So then after he signs the order threatens
to strip the funding, Broward said, well,
OK, hold up, we're going to rescind the mask
mandate.
We're not going to do it now.
We're not going to go along with it.
And then something amazing happened.
Several other counties, Leon County, which
is where Tallahassee, our capital is, they
said we're going to do mass for children,
at least for a couple of weeks.
Alachua County said, you know what, we're
going to do the same thing.
Orange County, of course, was doing it.
Then after everybody else jumped in, Broward
County came back and said, you know what,
we are going to put our mask mandates in place
to protect our children as they go to school.
Other school districts are currently actually
today having meetings about whether or not
to put mandates in place to protect.
I think it's usually about K through eight
children.
By putting mask mandates in place, obviously,
if they hit 12 years old, they're eligible
for the vaccine, but that's of little comfort
to parents who have children, basically sixth
grade or younger at this point.
So what's happening now is they are essentially
daring the governor saying we're putting these
mandates in place, we're going to protect
these kids, you've told us you're going to
strip our funding.
What are you going to do about it?
Basically playing a game of chicken with this
little wannabe Florida dictator, and I love
it, I love it not just because of the political
stance that they're taking, trying to say
you cannot have ultimate authority over every
single aspect of the state.
There are certain things that as a school
board, as a county, we can do to protect our
residents.
But most importantly, because the legal showdown
that if Santos chooses to enforce any of his,
you know, rules, this thing is going to go
to court.
And there it's a mixed bag.
Especially down here in Florida courts, we
have seen some horrible decision come from
some ridiculously right wing packed courts,
so it's likely they could side with Governor
de Santos.
It's also just as likely that in the interest
of the public's health, safety and welfare,
they could say that, no, the counties are
exercising their authority to protect their
residents.
Again, because of the makeup of the courts,
not just here, but on the appellate level
as well, it's a mixed bag and we really can't
predict or even pretend to know what kind
of decision we would actually get from any
of these courts.
But we can hope.
And I think right now, that's probably the
best we have, because here's what's happening,
the public is actually starting to, in small
ways, turn on Rhonda Santurce, who, as we
all know, is essentially at this point the
heir apparent to Donald Trump's political
apparatus.
Should Donald Trump not run for president
again in twenty twenty four to Santos has
been rising and those nationwide Republican
polls.
But over the past couple of weeks, the polls
down here in Florida telling us a much different
story as it stands right now in granite.
I'll give you this.
There's one poll where de Santos is now losing
to Democratic rival Charlie Crist, who actually
used to be our Republican governor.
Now he says he's a Democrat.
But anyway, he's beating Ronda Santos by one
point in the latest poll, 45 percent Crist,
44 percent to Santos.
And the poll, of course, has a one point six
percent margin of error.
And we're still 15 months out from the actual
election.
So the poll doesn't mean a whole heck of a
lot.
But it is showing us that at least some people
here in the state are paying attention, they're
watching as we have days where we literally
have tens of thousands of people coming down
with covid, where we send thousands more to
the hospital.
Because of this, children are being hospitalized
at an alarming rate here in the state of Florida.
And to Santurce would rather make this into
a political issue than a public health issue.
Earlier this week, you know, he got into a
bit of a tiff, I guess you'd call it, with
the White House, because Joe Biden called
him out, said, you know, Florida, Texas, you
know, either do what you need to do or stay
out of our way so we can do what we need to
do to protect people.
And to Santurce fired back at a press conference,
said, I'm going to stand in the way all the
way.
That means putting our kids in danger.
Another story came out this week from Politico,
where they talked to administrators, school
board members and principals from schools
across Florida, and a lot of them told the
same story.
You know, as I mentioned, schools starting
in just three days at this point.
Some of them don't have the staff to do it.
Either because they've had to bury too many
of them in recent months due to covid or because
they have suffered massive outbreaks once
teachers went back, you know, teachers always
have that week of preplanning.
Everybody got exposed, so now you have schools
that are going to start, some of them having
teachers in the double digits out on quarantine,
they don't have the staff to run their schools.
One said, we're literally losing our workforce,
that is the quote, literally losing our workforce.
And to Santurce won't let us protect our our
teachers or our kids.
I'm hoping he backs off this, but honestly,
I don't think he will, because for him, this
truly is a political statement, has nothing
to do with science, has nothing to do with
the safety of people here in the state of
Florida.
It's all politics.
And he is pandering to the worst of the worst.
And if he wants a bit of a lesson in how that
turns out, he needs
to look over to
the state of Arkansas.